I know you've said this whole thing with
Taylor Swift first of all Travis Kelce
has to marry Taylor Swift right he's
crazy why why why why what are you
talking about he will then get a movie
career he'll be bigger than the rock
okay I mean this is it this is his
chance that's that's fair first of all
let's say this he is a two-time Super
Bowl champion he's on the verge of
potentially being a three-time Super
Bowl champion universally recognized as
one of the greatest tit end in the
history of football good looking dude
got style got flare he's got skills he's
got a future in this business and this
business right here once he retires from
football I'm here to tell you that
because he's got the look he's got the
style he's got the statute he's got the
Pizzaz he's the total package okay and
he's a really really good dude Travis he
doesn't need her don't get me wrong T
Swift is a good-look woman she's an
incredible artist I went to her concert
with my daughter you went to her concert
I went to her concert man Howard it was
off the chain you loved it it was off
the chain I loved it I couldn't believe
how much I Lov I don't listen to Tor swi
music but until until that day she was
phenomenal I went to sofa stadium in La
my daughter Samantha was with me cuz she
had already want to see it with my
daughter Nyla she wanted to go back and
and I said come on baby we can go no
problem and she had an absolute blast I
saw Taylor Swift receive a 9 minute
standing ovation in between songs they
wouldn't let her these little girls
these little girl look they know every
song they know every lyric of every song
black white
Latina Asian really everything
everything it was a mosaic I saw
everything I saw everything wow and I'm
telling you right now no one was sitting
down Howard the concert was 3 and 1/2
hours non-stop there was no intermission
Howard are you ready for for this go
ahead I'm 56 years
old I stood up for the 3 and 1/2 hours I
never sat down look at you I didn't sit
down for three and a half
hours